ce qui est parti le raid qui est parti
et
on va suivre la finale ensemble on va
suivre cette finale ensemble on va
suivre cette finale ensemble stress est
présent n'était
et elle est portée cette auto promo de
l'auto promo c'est pas ma chaîne perso
ça saigne duchess comme la prépa s'est
bien passé ouais ce que ça donne une
chance de gagner à oui il n'est pas
favori mais une chance de gagner et
j'espère que la prépa va passer je vous
dirais ainsi ça se passe bien
l'ouverture ou pas on le verra ensemble
ça les amis wilson et forme efforts way
attendait
petit un petit bien sûr sur mon twitter
je m
vidéo sur mon twitter je pense que vous
allez la reconnaître je vais pas la
passer en entier mais le temps de
récupérer dia à les gens voient lien
j'envoie le lien
allez
j'envoie le tweet le tweet qui par sa et
le tweet est parti ah bah oui il faut se
présenter il faut se présenter ce soir
côté français forget je vais aller je
vais aller écouter les interviews pour
me faire un avis du délire je vais aller
écouter les
review préfinale ça parle ça parle de
l'association caritative sur les
caniveaux sarde
[Musique]
les étudiants français
c'est pas qu'on ait eu de dons sur la
chaîne en anglais au final mais croit
qu'il ya beaucoup de dons sur un cahier
plus de 200 mille dollars déjà 32 milles
je pensais qu'il y avait beaucoup plus
je n'arrive pas à voir c'est pas 320
milles ces 20 32 milles
ah je vois pas bien c'est petit c'est
pour tout le tournant c'est que ce soir
38 c'est pas beaucoup en vrai hikaru sur
une soirée le jour il a fait 270 milles
ou 250000 sais plus combien c'est fou
après ces petits là sur l'écran j'ai pas
mis en vente écrit le cache pas il
apparaît non il ya une partie qui va aux
associations espas il a dit qu'ils
avaient une 98000 au total ah ouais
c'est pas énorme en bref presque cent
mille vrai mais je crois que chess
camille double la mise donc ça va faire
deux cent mille au final
pace owen wilson après c'était une vraie
assauts enfin j'imagine
on va voir les gars ce que ça va donner
un peu de stress évidemment on va on va
voir moche moins stressé que pour les
autres matches parce que les autres
matches fait l'ouverture était vraiment
déterminante
c'était comme je disais un peu favori
contre x qc ludwig c'était vraiment
important qu'on tombe bien dans les
ouvertures aujourd'hui l'ouverture a son
importance mais c'est plus le milieu de
jeu parce que rennes où il sonne il
frappe à l'adil dans l'ouverture et il
fera surtout la diff en milieu de jeu et
je pense qu'il va essayer d'éviter les
positions complexes donc on va pas
pouvoir le le battre dans l'ouverture
on va voir le match
commencer je vais je peux mettre en fait
un faux l'eau sardo chez ch'ti et ça
devrait ça devrait suivre dès que le
match se lance sa attendant on va voir
je vous dirai si la prépa est passé ou
pas si c'est ce qu'on a regardé ou pas
aujourd'hui sarah shahi secours
populaire way l'association la maison au
bord du lac ouais je veux rire le cahier
pour ça redonne on va voir je vais vous
dire je suis toute façon je sais on a
regardé ça ensemble et c'est moi qui
vais préparer son truc donc je sais
exactement si on tombe dedans ou pas je
vais vous le dire tu connais le pas
et parker ouais je connais le cahier
parker donc on va voir les amis il n'y a
plus qu'à attendre maintenant le travail
a été fait je vais pouvoir retrouver des
nuits de sommeil normal à partir de
demain on va dire ce que j'avais un peu
stressé à partir de demain les nuits les
nuits vont se normaliser
donc là je suis un petit peu plus
détendu un peu plus détendre parce qu'il
ya le la pression qui se relâchent déjà
en vrai je peux plus rien faire
à présent je peux plus rien faire je
peux pas l'aider plus que ce que tu que
tout ce que j'ai fait donc on va dire
que mon rôle et est passé on n'a plus
qu'à regarder la fusée s'envoler ou
s'écraser on verra bien mais là
tout a été fait j'avais à faire ton
patrick bruel non non je vais vous dire
je vous dis ça tombe dans ce qu'on a
regardé ou pas je vais je vais vous le
dire immédiatement ans et 55 ans non je
pensais du 80/20 pour pour rennes mais
je vais vous dire que l'ouverture peut
passer sans 50 50 mais c'est compliqué
parce que c'est orange qui a pris par
irène wilson et je pense qu'il va avoir
il va essayer juste de sortir des
ouvertures vite parce qu'il sait que le
danger réside dans l'ouverture
donc je j'ai peur d'un d'une solution
trouvée par par wrench pour juste sortir
de l'ouverture vite car audi
favori mais hikaru mettre la pression
sur sarde pour sirène wilson farrell
wilson nous rappelle qu'il a joué en
équipe universitaire aux états unis dans
son université aux échecs il a il a 30
40 ans d'échec il a énormément joué dans
sa jeunesse
évidemment rennes mulsanne est favori
maintenant on va dire que l'ouverture
est primordial mais on a moins la main
que comptent les deux autres adversaires
on va être contre ludwig est contre et
contre x qc fallait vraiment pas se
rater dans l'ouverture parce qu'on
aurait été dominés dans le milieu de jeu
derrière et ça aurait été la cata ils
étaient bien préparés aussi ron wilson
essaye juste de sortir vite de
l'ouverture et joue un truc malin pour
avoir un mileu de jeu parce qu'il est
vraiment nettement plus fort que les
autres donc on va voir ça dépend
vraiment des coachs bercy ouais on va
voir si on tombe dedans on a plutôt de
la chance en fait et surtout qu'on sait
pas
bluffé qui jouait vraiment beaucoup
mieux que le niveau qu'il a montré
jusque là si j'avais 40 ans
van dyk pour son poulain ouais bah oui
on a éliminé de plus ou moins tout le
monde et ludwig aussi été une grosse
élimination allez on va
ah je suis un petit peu impatient
j'espère que ça recommence blanc mais
bon comment
c'est noir fait peut-être pas une grosse
différence sac alors c'est maintenant il
est blanc
on va voir on va voir
et blanc c'est là que je me pose le plus
de questions sur ce qu'ils ont préparée
je suis un peu inquiet mais bon je suis
un peu
yeah
les sas
à partir la dent d'un instant à l'autre
il est trop en stress fait voir il faut
il faut surtout pas qu'ils seraient si
stress on a vraiment aucune chance
faut vraiment pas qu'ils pensent qu'il
est favori parce que c'est pas le cas
mais il car on a réussi à leur mettre la
pression le donnant favori quoi c'est
terrible comme il est malin hikaru il
est tellement malin hikaru il nous fait
chier jusqu'au bout hikaru c'est
incroyable qu'est-ce qu'il est malin
c'est pas possible c'est vraiment un
marlou des îles un ste marlou d'icare ou
non mais
évite tout mettre sur sa revanche c'est
pas possible car oui mais tellement
foule pression allez c'est parti
sardasht qu'ils allaient noir pour la
première je vais vous dire si ça rentre
la prépa ok donc 4 c 5 ont jusque là
c'était prévu cavalier f3e 6 et là on a
et b3
stresse un peu en fait après si fin
merde c'est tant mieux
jean on les en faisant un peu triquet
parce qu'il a préparé la nage d'art fred
wilson
ils avaient préparé des 6es sur ok donc
des gens les akènes je pense mais oui la
prépa qui rentre à laymont sarthe
cavaliers c6 des cinq déjà ça fait
plaisir
déjà ça fait plaisir devinez et oui
devine aide
bon ça veut rien dire mais c'est déjà
une bonne nouvelle ça fait plaisir
saab et écoles le b3 le cahier qui
rentrent immédiatement prévu prévu parce
qu'ils jouaient des six jouets b3 sur
des cistes et du coup la sueur
réussissons à pouvoir règle des 5 savent
et écoles bon allez ça veut rien dire
parce que c'est une position très
compliquée qui va peut-être avantage est
quand même rennes parce que le milieu
est pas simple mais au moins on met
sarde dans les meilleures conditions
possibles
on a mis ça dans les meilleures
conditions possibles ici on ne pouvait
pas faire mieux pour les noirs on
pouvait pas faire mieux et des 5
mais voilà on a
tu prépares est énorme mais on a
développement n'a pris le centre on a on
a on a la position qu'on voulait e5
alors ça précisément on n'a pas regardé
mais c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que
c'est un mauvais coup après je sais pas
si ça devait avoir le cavalier sept
cavaliers 5 mai
dams et sept cavaliers 7 kg 6 aussi si
ça y va la voir
puis on le 5 il va la voir parce que
lecavalier en f3 si si on en a parlé de
ça mais pas dans cette position précise
on en a parlé après cavaliers f6 de
cavaliers 17
donc on n'a pas parlé de cinq direct
mais ici peut voir dame ses sept
cavaliers 7 kg 6 ok la balle est dans
son camp quand même il faut quand même
qu'ils voient quelque chose tout seul la
sarde qui a valu aux sept cavaliers g6
il doit la voir quand même ouais dames
c'est cette fois juste sur cavaliers c3
qui fatto kefu b5 ça ça doit pas
l'inquiéter du tout à mon avis va faire
fou 17 pour essayer qu'il prend 1,5 à
appréhender cette caisse est cool c'est
cool parce que c'est dans le exactement
dans le daniel reyne jh de ce qu'on
avait de ce qu'on a de ce dont on avait
parlé food et 7 sté sûr mais est sûr
qu'il prend le 5e long il faut prendre 5
donc heureusement qu'il a pris et la
sarthe va reprendre du fou je pense
ouais ouais c'est bien c'est parfait
ok ces trois lots tu veux jouer pour des
4 pour entrer dans une structure
française ça peut avoir des foules et
sinko intéressant ici il faut que
mais mon l'ouverture est quand même une
réussite je vous cache pas ça c'est pas
ok il a modifié à eux cinq et sajoo mais
j'étais plutôt c'est plutôt bien pour
nous sauver 5 c'est vraiment fort je
pense dans l'esprit avec un maillage six
cavaliers f5 mais ça c'est des plans qui
n'a pas forcément à après s'il a regardé
le ciss rappelle du match
bon on peut avoir une énorme réussite
parce que c'est la même structure que
dans le match de benji fichiers et il
peut avoir le cavalier h six cavaliers
f5 on en avait parlé
c'est une super française en fait il a
une superbe
cabello 7-6
les f-5 aussi ouais mais cavaliers h6
laisse du d4 puis on prend puis on prend
et fourbe et quatre dans le règne mon
cavalier e set c'est aussi dans le bon
tempo
par contre quand le pion vient en d4 va
pas qu'il aille en justice saura qu'il
aille en f5 et ça va il a 7 7 37 49 même
c'est parfait des quatre là il peut
échanger s'il veut je pense qu'il va le
faire
après je pense que à cavaler f5 et plus
au pied après le problème ces créneaux
his own est tellement plus fort dans les
milieux de jeu ça le problème
c'est dans ces milieux-là jeu là en fait
sarni l'a pas encore dans son ranch des
coups comme fou b5 et
je pense que justin joue beaucoup mieux
ces structures c'est ça le souci en fait
mais bon ça on peut rien y faire
malheureusement les poubelles 5
dil rocks à contrôler la faim mais
maintenant il ya cavaliers ces trois
fois ci c'est à 4 il n'y a pas de fous
b4 clouage pascal cavagnan e7 qui va
faire cavalier f5 et c'est quand même
mieux cavaliers g6 c'est pas aux petits
aux petits mais ça va il faut 7 et erroc
il ya plus le fou de cases blanches pour
rennes wilson et c'est clairement dans
le domaine
avec toi et tous les cinq
d'activer le fouet
en tout cas bonne
je vous donnais une éval d'ordi mefou b4
fo b4 j'aime pas trop voit plutôt un set
lors didonne égalerait non l'ouverture
l'ouverture est vraiment bien sorti côté
noir veut de large et la torah il veut
faire flouer 5 pour gagner la tour ouais
mais ça ça va jamais arrivé les blancs
n'importe quel coût des blancs empêche
le l'idée en fait j'aurais à trois noms
mais ok du coup au moins qui fasse foi 5
fu fu b6 pour retaper sur le pion des 4
après faire un fou en deux sets mais bon
parti pour partie ok là on touche 1
faible de sartre quand même
stratégiquement c'est que ça ça reste un
peu un jeu pour des tactiques et là la
position est très fermé mais bon il se
trouve que le fourbe et si c'est pas si
mal placé mais il pourra
mes cavaliers c3 est sûre à 5 pour
casser il y aura peut-être b 5 à 4 mais
bon ça va ça va honnêtement ça aurait pu
être bien pire ça aurait pu être bien
pire tour un mois il va peuvent faire
rock il va pouvoir jouer pour f6
peut-être un cas un truc hein
récent c'est fou baies 5 pouces et 4
mais ça aussi c'est un peu dur encore
enfin dans l'idée 1
mais bon et rock joué ça va
ok position pollution très très
équilibré maintenant est-ce qu'il va
avoir dans le règne des dames 17 fourbe
et 5 pouces et quatre tours c8 jouait la
colonne c'est ok caïds et 2 je suis
plutôt content le cavalier allez plutôt
en c3 d'après mois après il veut
peut-être touché la case ses 5 mai sur
cavaliers b3 y aura un fou à 4 faut-il
encore le voir là normalement faut aller
jouer la colonne c'est et sortir la fin
peut-être commencer par tour c'est
l'utopie à 5 est aussi un bon coup
parce que comme il n'a pas fait cavalier
c3 ya pas b5 donc c'est dans le règne
des coûts plus que correct fait il est
bien parce que regarder le fou b2c le
mauvais fout des blancs c'est équivalent
au pouce et 6 entre guillemets mais elle
fut celle ci s'il a plus d'avenir que le
four b2 le fourbe et 6,6 tape sur la
structure de pions donc les noirs ou une
position plutôt correct a joué juste ici
faut pas laisser cavaliers c'est ça
qu'il faut faire x 4 et changer le fou
contre le cavaliere et ses bons fous
contre mauvais fou mais bon ça c'est pas
dans le ranch de de sarnaut encore ce
genre de coups mais là après fou à 4
sardeha moins un sur l'ordi quand même
fou à 4 c - 1 a laissé l'ouverture c'est
vraiment très bien passé 1 il ya aussi
apprend b4 peut-être comme beaucoup ab
tour prend à prisa est fou baisse
pour tous ces quatre qui peut aussi être
une option et les noirs sont vraiment
super bien sortie de l'ouverture non là
c'est le cai a encore frappé quand même
le b3 et écoles six dessins de jouer
les noirs sont avantagés ouais mais bon
une nouvelle fois le problème de cette
prépa c'est que dans les autres on a
réussi à avoir des positions que sartre
jouais bien et là ce qui m'embête dans
salaam et on pouvait rien faire pour
l'empêcher c'est qu'on tombe dans une
position où règnent wilson joue plutôt
mieux mais on ne pouvait pas empêcher
rennes wilson d'accepter un désavantage
pour avoir une meilleure position
c'est juste impossible x 4
c'est visible ans un clouage pour jouer
dame c4 ou pour échanger à laisser jouer
et d'amd
3 c'est un bon coup mais là en fait tu
peux échanger tu restes en fait si tu
fais juste ça georges juste mettre une
position lambda genre ça ça avant
noir parce qu'on a le bon fou contre le
mauvais fou mais je pense pas que ce
soit dans son règne stratégique
malheureusement bon après sur retour ces
huit tours serre y avait d'armes
français 1 qui gagne et c'était juste
que je voulais montrer une variante
c'est pas c'est pas un truc précis mais
genre ça ça ça ça et ça c'est hyper
scolaire et c'est hyper fort en fait tu
gagnes la colonne s'est tu donnes pas là
colonna parce que tu contrôles à 7 et tu
vas juste vouloir rentrer dedans tu vas
faire h si ces dames ces deux étaient
juste mieux mais la sarre 10 mais trop
mal autant il sait pas quoi jouer et
c'est dommage
c'est dommage c'est le problème c'est ce
qui c'est
te ment ce qui m'inquiétait dans le
match en fait c'est vraiment
exactement ce qui m'inquiétait c'était
position on réussisse à trouver
davantage dans la prépa mais que la
position était trop complexe à jouer
effet dame c4 direct et du coup ils s
cavaliers c5 et il va garder son mauvais
fou alors c'est pas gravissime mais
c'est tellement dommage de pas échangé
le mauvais font la leçon sur les bons
fous et mauvais fou qui n'a pas été
retenue terrible mais j'ai su qu'il
pouvait pas faire vous prend b3
karoubi
hier alors ça c'est probablement faux on
met 3 était le plus logique c'est
confirmé par l'andi mais bon c'est en
fait il a un tel avantage que ça remet
pas en cause le fait qu'ils aient une
position correcte
ça n'enlève pas en fait l'avantagé enfin
on a tellement réussi à dominer
l'ouverture que cette erreur la remet
pas en cause qui les biens et le move
est fou c'est le fou de cases blanches
parce que les pions sont sur case
blanche
donc c'est le mauvais fouet le bon fou
c'est le foot cases noires parce que
c'est les pions adverse qui sont sur
cannes noirs donc c'est un fou offensif
le cas
bien joué là il a un petit choc avec du
dame prend des trois fous b5 pour
rejouer la casse ces quatre peut-être
qui peut être intéressant et cavani les
chiens ici il va sûrement faire [ __ ]
en c5 connaissance hard fait ça fera
d'un français 4 dépenser quatre reprises
ces cinq et peut-être tenté un fou c6 ou
des cinq pour revenir jouer à le fou ici
je suis un peu inquiet quand même on a
obtenu une bonne position mais un
mauvais match up mais un mauvais trucs
pour le match je pense pas que dame
prend marche ici d'avoir un fou à 3 qui
fait mal avec une tour qui sera en l'air
en fuite à la fin de la variante mais là
problème de temps et ils échangent les
dames cavaliers prend
cavalier qui va
venir en c5 hockey reste plus que de 30
oui clairement
la position clairement il est pas super
à l'aise
oh là là j'ai 5 ha ouais ok heureusement
qui est rangée 5 a prises ici mais il
peut y avoir un g4 en premier
intermédiaire fera g5 c'est tellement
pas un bon coup j'ai quatre joueurs en
ce sens instanz karen ok mais cavaliers
h catherine tout cas étrange et 5h six
cavaliers bouger cavaliers f3 mais c'est
trop dur en baccarat lieu ça t'es qu'un
étranger 5t peut retourner avec du
cavalier c6 encore peut-être qu'ils
accueillent g5 et ses six attaques des
quatre cavaliers froid foulée cinq
attaques des trois cavaliers bouche bée
éperon b4 et sur cavaliers prend 17
cavaliers detroit
ah ouais c'est même pas sûr que ça
fonctionne mais ça peut être sa seule
chance est là il a vraiment été dominés
beaucoup trop fort rennes en fait c'est
pour ça on a réussi une nouvelle fois à
dominer l'ouverture mais auquel le truc
c'est que le mec joue beaucoup mieux en
face quoi qu'est ce tu veux faire
qu'est-ce que tu
faire avec
5 intermédiaire ok c'est très bien joué
parce qu'en fait ils attaquent le x 4 ok
mais c'est super bien joué fr il fait
pas cavalier f3 il revient directement
ses 5 mai
mais bon il y aura rien à se reprocher
les amis rennes est beaucoup trop fort
ouais faut qu'il faut espérer une erreur
random la position est pas si grave en
réalité elle est pas si perdante que ça
parce qu'il ya [ __ ] couleurs opposées
donc ça favorise la nul et qu'il ya
beaucoup de pions sur noir qui sont
bloqués manqué là il a juste très bien
joué mais bon ok il peut il peu gaffe et
qui sait mettre tour deux c'est encore
bien jouer peut-être un fou b saint
calais a foulé 5 peut être marlou une
tour prend un tour à huit tours à 2
à tours prend à 4 tours france et 2 mais
bon non mais c'est la différence de
niveau est beaucoup beaucoup trop grande
beaucoup trop
en cas et c2c des coûts trop naïfs en
fait même tour c'est un par la menace
obligé de repartir en b 4 mais oui tu en
prends à cathy le voit évidemment brême
après est-ce pas ok il n'a pas le niveau
mais honnêtement il ya rien à se
reprocher là c'était impossible de
rattraper red wilson il joue vraiment
beaucoup trop bien il joue vraiment très
très bien honnêtement c'est normal que
sar de père dont il a vraiment pas à
rougir
il a pas il a pas à rougir
en fait on a réussi à avoir la prépa
avoir la meilleure position mais qu'elle
est juste difficile à jouer le mec en
face joue vraiment bien
hello
parti à part l'ouverture
1600 1700 ouais on va avoir ce genre de
position là il peut y avoir un truc
bizarre c'est qu'au niveau amateur ça
peut être plus facile à jouer pour les
noirs mais bon là encore ils trouvent le
bon plan rennes où il sonne on est ok
mais il est vraiment fort ça dégoûte
ce que sarlat il vient de bien jouer la
série de coups de sardes est très bonne
mais elle a encore rennes où il sonne je
vous les meilleurs coups a ok ok ils
trouveront fr droit des trois c'est
peut-être pas si dur mais c'est juste
qu'ils tombent toujours dans la cible
tu peux
faire honnêtement ouais c'est marrant
disque stardash est favori et où parce
que quand tu vois le niveau de rennes où
il sonne à ok c'est la même différence
de niveau qui est entre moi et peut-être
pas hikaru mais un mec vraiment bon
genre maronite ce qui est genre tu me
donnes deux parties ok tu me donnes des
bonnes ouvertures dont impose une bonne
position 10 dans les ouvertures mais
montchaude pour gagner vraiment petit la
face ardila une toute petite chance de
gagner mais elle est minuscule et la
sarre die fait plutôt une bonne partie
dirais que globalement sa partie est
vraiment correct ok il ya eu quelques
petites fautes mais pour son niveau il a
fait une vraiment bonne partie il s'est
rappelé de l'ouverture et il a assez
bien joué le milieu de jeu après l'autre
est juste plus fort g5 ce n'était pas
une mauvaise idée mais il a fait chez
cap tempo quand même pas ok là c'était
vraiment impressionnant quand il a fait
g5
il faut trouver le g4 quand même il faut
trouver le g4 cavaliers cette prise
cavaliers c6 est là il faut encore voir
qu'il faut commencer par cavalier c5
parce que le pion des quatre est menacée
si tu commences par cavalier 3 yacoub et
5 qui va attaquer le cavalier gagné b4
donc il fallait encore enfin la séquence
j'ai quatre cavaliers pranger 5 et
cavaliers c5 c'est vraiment très dur
c'est c'est vraiment même pas 15 cents
en fait est là il va lui faire roi b3
qui a validé deux ans ferme en de
tournon mais en fait tu peux rien faire
aidé de il restera 4 mai à séquence a
été vu ba le truc c'est qu'il a quand
même vu pas mal de choses difficiles
d'un point de vue général et même si on
a réussi un peu le piéger dans
l'ouverture on a pas on n'aura pas fait
beaucoup plus ouais il faisait des
débours d'ignobles avant il a summer
clairement c'est pas possible en fait
dans le tournoi il a fait plein de game
où il y avait des bleus under de ouf
c'est impossible
il joue beaucoup trop bien mais
que fait sardasht honnêtement il pourra
être content de son match et de sa
partie au caire
la part de sardes aller là il fait une
excellente finale c'est la meilleure
finale qui joue depuis le début au caire
bien énorme erreur alger oulala il est
gagnant sarde
non pourquoi tu fais cheikh pourquoi
prend son [ __ ] de pions mais nan mais
[ __ ] mais pourquoi il prend pas le
pion pourquoi il prend pas le pion
pourquoi tu le prends pas [ __ ] il a
trois cases de dames
mais pourquoi il prend pas ce [ __ ] de
pions mais pourquoi c'est pas possible à
gg 3g 2 il avait tellement troll rennes
où il sonne
il avait tellement troll comment il
prend pas ce pion mais comment il prend
pas ce pion aux non il va faire froid
quatre cavaliers g3 non non non non non
ça va ils voient non pourquoi il n'a pas
pris pourquoi il n'a pas pris allez tout
reprend h4 prend les pions bordel prend
les pions qu'on te donne mais non ils
donnent la tour en un [ __ ] j'en peux
plus j'en peux plus
il a turbo troll il a turbo troll
oh non il jouait pas du tout à 710 700
la renault nissan sur la partie non
tellement drôle il a tellement trois
noms allez il veut essayer d'échanger
les pions est rentrée dans le fou
cavaliers au non je ne peux plus il
fallait rendre le fou cavaliers au nom
la déception la partie ça va à quoi il a
craqué en fait la prépa est rentré le
milieu dieu a vraiment été dominée par
rennes wilson il a fait une énorme gaffe
j'avais juste à prendre roger catez
poussé le pion
quoi il essaye pas b6 pourrait changer
au moins non là il ya plus deux nuls
il peut plus rien faire il est bloqué
comment il n'a pas pris angers 4 en fait
l'option il était il était il était
donné
je comprends pas en fait mon temps là
1 c'est le temps mais je comprends pas
pourquoi il a fait h5 et la paperie g4 à
je suis tellement dégoûté je suis
tellement dégoûté vous n'imaginez même
pas ouais non c'est le stress un bien
sûr
ici c'est inquiète ouais
leur ivoire c'est la pression il s'est
trop mis la pression
c'est qu'il a vraiment beaucoup raté qui
a jugé travailler aussi tout reprend h4
et il aller la gagner la finale en fait
c'est dommage
[Musique]
après hikaru il a raison c'est une
question de bien jouer sous pression
mais à jouer sous pression
il a pas tord écart ou là dessus ça
après c'est très individuel un tas de
gens qui jouent mieux sous pression et
on a d'autres qui jouent moins bien ça
c'est tout un chacun
ouais mais ils ont les deux shows qu'un
ya pas qu il n'y a pas que ça tchatche
aucun mais c'est tellement dommage qui
fait pions pranger 4 la position elle
est tellement dure à jouer pour les
blancs il manage âgées 3g 2 juin il
aurait fait foulant pour cover tour
prend des 4 et c'était quasiment gagné
la balle et vas-y tu écris
allez
précision de wilson wilson a fait une
bonne partie mais il a fait une énorme
gaffe il peut avoir une grosse précision
d'après le redis 95.8 en fait à part la
gaffe qu'il a fait il a fait une partie
sans erreur wilson mise à part son
cavalier b en fait il a fait une partie
quasi parfaite juste 0
six erreurs mais bon alors niveau c'est
vraiment vraiment bien quoi mais
honnêtement il a fait une très bonne
partie au ray nixon pour leur niveau
salle afin qu'il a fait des erreurs et
la séquence avait caché mais sinon il a
très bien joué
on va
si la prépa
la première je suis confiant pour la
deuxième
à fait 95.5 ce que c'est une position
ferme et sens tactique et que je vous
suis super bien rennes où il s'adonne ya
pas de ya pas de magouilles à rien c'est
juste un bon joueur après il fait des
gaffes de temps en temps parce que parce
que parce qu'en vrai à partir d'un
certain âge ça vient plusieurs de garder
la concentration longtemps ça t'as plein
de grands maîtres qui me l'ont dit qu'à
partir de 45 50 même pour des pour des
grands maîtres ça devient beaucoup plus
dur de jouer sans gaffe jamais il ya
déjà des sautes de concentration qui
arrive plus souvent que quand on a moins
de moins de 35 40
j'ai peur que ça m'arrive un jour mais
mais du coup c'est il a juste une très
bonne compréhension rainn wilson mais
gaf un peu célia quoi je sais pas
honnêtement je ne sais pas mais c'est
quelque chose de connu genre tout le
monde c'est ok mais
j'espère la deuxième aussi le b3 cette
école j'avais vraiment cole l'ouverture
exacte aujourd'hui mais là ça va
passer à l'est c'est l'écart entre deux
joueurs est trop grand et un petit temps
à taper en quel sens c'est impossible en
fait là le niveau que fait ça par
rapport aux entraînements qu'on a fait
et où c'est vraiment le max de ce qu'on
pouvait faire une fille donne vraiment
le max après ça se joue à je prends g4
ratée où trouver ça se joue à rien mais
ça joue un peu plus dans la tête
qu'autre chose c'est pas facile c'est
une finale c'est dur il a 57 ans rainn
wilson omc pour ça en fait en vrai je
pense que son niveau de jeu global soit
1800 1900 mhz et il fait des gaffes de
800 de temps en temps donc c'est pour ça
qu'il joue pas à 10 810 900 mais sinon
ça joue vraiment bien
le g4 cas et c5 et où qu'il a trouvé
c'était vraiment bien mais des fois il
décroche c'est pour ça c'est un genre
aurait enfin maso sur internet amazon en
réalité il fait moins de gaffes mais
c'est un genre de maso en title tuesday
en fait il peut la colla tomaszewski et
perdre contre un mec complètement random
bon là toute la question c'est est est
ce qu il allait faire un counter de
londres ou pas toute la question qu'on
s'est posée
moi je suis parti du principe qu'il a
joué des 5-6 l'habitude et que s'ils
changent et là il a changé
ok ça c'était un des risques
c'était qui changent alors la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est qu'on n'a pas préparé ça
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il a été
obligé de changer londres parce qu'il
n'aime pas du tout et qui va pas trop
connaître et eux qui en a un petit peu
parlé de ça si ça rate ce rappel dans
les mp qui m'envoyait tout à l'heure ils
me posaient la question là dessus
ah merde de4 eca réalisé trois là dessus
non
ça on a déjà joué des comme ça en vrai
là c'est comment dire le truc c'est que
rennes ont ils savent tous vraiment
jamais ça
wilson jouvray
ça donc ça
c'est mai
c'est
on va voir
peut il peut faire cavalier avec six
dames des deux fois à six a attaqué le
rock le fj enquête au hockey mais rennes
où il sonne fait n'importe quoi en vrai
bon ça c'est un des trucs que je ne
savais pas ce qui pouvait se passer
cette sirène ou wilson voulait
absolument éviter london est joint un
truc qui maîtrisent pas du tout en gros
ça se passe plutôt bien pour les blancs
mais après on va voir ça tzigane qui
prend tout le centre il ya deux filles
enquêteurs il va faire une ruse ok va
faire une méthode ruiz quoi et ça
évidemment n'avait pas pu voir ça
évident
pas pu prévoir mais bon ça à double
tranchant puisque la wii c'est vraiment
de la merde pour les noirs c'est fait il
a été obligé de faire ça pour éviter
auquel fois 6-1 flash si chaque est
programmé fouache 6 il a le temps sur
fou prend des quatre qui prend des
quatre qui prend des katas fou g7 et sur
x 6 food et 4 et sur fois ci ce qui est
des cats il prend g7 qui est là faut
vraiment qu'ils trouvent fois ci s'y
trouvent tous âges 6 ces gros avantage
je pense juste chèque avec l'ordi way
s'y trouvent fois ci c'est gros avantage
il fallait faire h6 pourrait nous ils
sonnent à y trouve pas et là il ya ka et
prend des quatre quand même et aux cinq
races et de
parce qu'il avait tout fait pour faire
flasher 6 et il est pas allé regarder si
le pion était vraiment menacée et
l'autre
me 17
la stratégie de renault y sonne comme il
est vraiment nettement plus fort en
stratégie vu jouer des positions fermes
et et jouer parce qu'ils jouent mieux
elle n'a pas eu foule g7 à la fin
c'est complexe
ouais alors niveau c'est pas une
mauvaise décision il n'a tellement pas
pu jouer contre le london qui il a joué
une ruse quoi terrible le conseil de
mazo c'était de jouer à 4 h 5 victoires
contre ça quant à carreaux
des stages favori mais hikaru il dit les
choses qu'ils arrangent les gars il veut
mettre la pression sur sarre d'achille a
compris qu'ils pouvaient tilt et du coup
il a compris que ne pas avoir de
pression était un avantage pour lui et
du coup il veut lui mettre la pression
c'est tout en fait
non
de la part de rainn wilson
bien ça se voit qu'il a préparé ça
vraiment que pour le match parce qu'il a
raté cac et prend des 4 40 fois qu'il a
laissée fourrage 6 donc il a joué assez
mal à rennes où il sonne aussi mais bon
bah c'est juste la différence de niveau
qui peut rien parce que là on fait tous
réfutent c'est encore une faute en fait
il ya énormément de fautes dans cette
partie ils voient pas que son coup
c'était eux c'est un coût qui prend des
4 et 5
comme je vous disais qu'il prend des
cats qui prend des quatre-cinq c'est
vraiment fort ça il rate beaucoup de
choses ça se voit qu'il est pas du tout
à l'aise rainn wilson
mais en fait c'est encore pire pour
sarde
c'est me dont il peut
lyon qui jouait mal mais qui pense mieux
jouer ex tarder c'est pas bête
c'est ce qui va voir qui prend des cats
et un peu moins grave où il ya même
cavalier à 5 mais c'est un peu quitte
pas mauvais mais en fait c'est un peu
moins chaud que tout à l'heure
parce que du coup il n'y a pas la
colonne des qui s'ouvre avec la tour
derrière il a jamais vu qu'elle prend
des 4 il faut quand même qu'ils rock un
moment sarde et qu'il essaie d'envoyer
ses 5
non non c'est compliqué pour les deux là
les deux jouent très mal cette position
c'est marrant c'est à celui qui jouera
le moins mal je pense à la vue faux
problème trois dames problème 3 into
damas huit matches ça peut tomber la
grèce
un poème banon mais s'explique vraiment
facilement à les gars ça s'explique
vraiment par le fait que qu'il a voulu
empêcher le truc ff5 c'est n'importe
quoi
enfin c'est pas
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi mais c'est
ça la partie n'a ni queue ni tête là on
sait pas pourquoi sa drogue jamais rock
et tourer et attaque 6 et prises des 6
ça va il faut vraiment qu'ils rock qui
peut pas garder le roi au centre aussi
longtemps en fort ok et tours et tourer
voilà games a vraiment ni queue ni tête
quoi honnêtement c'est très drôle
nantes
thor studio du tout là c'est juste qu'il
s'est vraiment pas jouer ces trucs là
juste franck et tourer en fait c'est
tellement simple et tata que six c'est
le point faible de la position adverse
et tu peux pas garder un roi au centre
aussi longtemps maintenant avec yahoo à
l'ailé menzah nice doit pas ce qu'on
comprend de quoi on parle
hikaru au fait y compris
même chose que moi en fait ces clés en
fait rennes a voulu jouer un counter
contre ce que fait sarde et du coup les
deux jouent très mal la tour d un c'est
juste très mal joué c'est vraiment
horrible à tous les coups son rythme de
la part des deux joueurs mais là faut
vraiment juste rock et tourer faut pas
se poser de question et c'est pour ça
défaut de sardasht comme ces dépositions
qu'on n'a pas pu étudier il se retrouve
vraiment a lâché dans
nature et c'est plus compliqué c'est son
point faible après ils ont ils ont tapé
le point faible
autant dans la première on a bien deviné
autant là la ruine j'aurais jamais pensé
qu'ils joueraient ça bien pensé après
c'était sûr qu'ils joueraient mal aussi
avec les noirs mais il va moins mal
jouer quoi jean larroque tour c'est
important ça fait rentrer la pièce en
jeu et ça tape sur 6 km et 3 c'est une
catastrophe ce coup c'est catastrophique
parce que sa menace rien je pense juste
un coup comme fou ces deux et jouable
ici mais les mois jours et rock quand
même il faut rockets et tours 1 là faut
prendre trois dames 1re 3 qui est des
quatre dames à huit échecs
tu peux montrer un et on rentre dans la
position et la fête
2 voilà la bonne nouvelle c'est que le
meilleur poussé cavaliers à 5
s'il fait [ __ ] en f3 dame price 3c
clutch parce que qu'elle prend des
quatre dames à 8 ça va il a trouvé
cavaliers à 5 ça dégoûte et erroc
maintenant au pire moment qu'un accueil
france et 4 quelle horreur cette horreur
il fallait le faire depuis tout à
l'heure prasad vers hockey depuis
dikoumé ok par chance il encore dame eux
deux et c'est très chaud le pire moment
quoi sur k et b3 il fallait faire rock
direct mais il a fait pousser de cavalia
5 très mal joué de la part des noirs et
contrefoutent petit rock pour qui les
prend ses quatre ans cette partie là
elle et elle est très très mauvaise
mais ok ça ou la colonne ces sages ou
encore mais juste offert dame de la
gamme autant
reparti a assez bien joué pendant
longtemps en temps ça là c'est une
catastrophe
mais parce que les deux joueurs ont
voulu enfin parce que la reine wilson il
a voulu vraiment c'est pas dit qu'ils
gagnent du tout en fait wilson ce que
dame de tours en attaque le pion aux six
avec la colonne s'est ouverte
honnêtement c'est beaucoup plus facile à
jouer pour les blancs genre la cac
les prend à trois marches pas du tout il
va y avoir un fou des trois dames à 2 et
le cavalier n'aura plus de cases peut
vous montrer aussi vous des trois ça
fait une focale ce qu'on appelle une
focale sur le cavalier sa contrôler
toutes ces cases on va pouvoir les
justes le ramasse avec la dame
donc il peut pas le faire il ya plus de
temps pour rennes où ils sont ok j'y
crois quand même truc c'est que la
position est tellement plus simple à
jouer pour les blancs la ruine break
auxquelles afu détroit et damas deux ses
gammes face et gap ces pièces de plus ou
même peut-être fou détroit et hourra
pour pas laisser les pions doublet
bright food et troyes et tours 1 c'est
vraiment terminé
trop c'est tellement c'est tellement une
focale on a tellement parlé de la focale
manqué four b3 peut aussi passer
peut-être fou des trois c'était vraiment
cadeau mais fou des trois peut marcher
parce que ça attaque 6 mais il faut
qu'ils voient que yaya toure a un qui
suis allé
croire quand même position est tellement
difficile à jouer pour les noirs comme
je vous disais truc c'est que la ruine
si tu joues ça en surprises c'est
vraiment double tranchant et on voit que
la prépa américaine n'a pas finalement
elle a fonctionné dans l'esprit mais la
position était trop difficile à
maîtriser et donc
et donc c'était plutôt une erreur je
pense de la part de rennes ch
mais ok là
retrouver peut-être fou à vous prend
vous prendre cavaliers prend il veut
pions prend tour à et cavaliers c4 c'est
compliqué ce qu'il faut qu'ils trouvent
et compliqué faut qu'il trouve un truc
comme ça mais c'est m
aignan mais le truc c'est que les noirs
ont du mal à défendre leurs dames c'est
cette qui prend ses quartiers en france
et quatre tours c1 il n'ya pas des 5
il ya des tours france et 4 qui traînent
dans l'esprit l'avez peut-être vous
prendrez 4 encore cette réussite food et
5 des 5 c'était réussite que ça tienne
mais ok c'est pas fait parce que fout
des cinq ça ça il va sûrement jouer
cavalier prend b5 et là il peut y avoir
un dame prend des 5 es le roi qui est
super faible ça peut encore le faire
mais je pense que alors un niveau va
être c'est un échec intermédiaire je
pense
heureusement qu'à leur niveau c'est plus
facile à jouer pour les noirs là
faudrait qu'ils trouvent sous préemption
prend des tours c'est si ce qui est très
fort encore parce que ça attaque ici
mais c'est très difficile à trouver pour
sait si c'est très dur à trouver
enfin si l'as v
le food et 3 c'était plus clair ok
trouver allez ça c'est un gros coup et
qui avait laissé quatre cavaliers des
deux allait si la cavale et ses quatre
cavaliers des deux ça peut aller
s'il n'a pas cavalier d2 par contre
c'est un coup d'épée dans l'eau maëlle
et il a trouvé le tour ces six là il a
trouvé un bon coup c'est le premier bon
coup de la partie mais il est de notre
côté cavalier c4 est là il faut
cavaliers des deux par contre si c'est
pas faux loi par cavalier d2 ça sert à
rien mais si c'est faux le parc a validé
deux ça met tellement de pression sur
des six il faut qu'ils comprennent c'est
pas le cavalier qui joue c'est dieu
enfin c'est dur si dur je le trouve
kazim sentent mai mais pour leur niveau
c'est difficile cavaliers des deux
salles enchaînement tour c'est ce qui a
aidé 2 6 le trouve
il fait très mal un truc c'est que ya
pas de fou prend des quatre parce qu'on
va pouvoir prendre en c4 et prend des
six est en fait on va gagner la partie
hinse tente ça l'idée
et
je sais pas après on fait un coup de
dames et sajoo 1 gère la partie n est
pas terminé mais on met grosse pression
du coup il va faire cailler des deux
tours des deux dames des deux tours au
6e tour c1 dames ses trois tours c 'est
tout damas de damas trois aussi possible
je suis là juste dame ces trois ans
rendre sur la colonne et on essaye de
mater en force
ça c'est faisable mais faut trouver
cavaliers des deux parce que sinon le
cavalier c4 il est trop fort et tour
c'est un seul c'est pas le meilleur coup
mais il se laisse cavaliers d2 par la
suite donc tour c'est un pour commencer
ça peut aller
trouvez tour c'est un c'était coup
numéro 2 qu'il se passe quoi surtout en
france et 4 en france et quatre tours
prend des six dames c'est cet ail a pas
de bonnes découvertes
malheureusement il ya encore du dames 6
dan des cinq mais c'est très chaud à
trouver ce que l'idée c'est tout reprend
b6 si on prend b6 d'un plan b si c'est
fou prend ses sept
mais c'est très dur ok ok faut il est
choqué renke iatchouk au tour ses huit
tours pensée 4 il n'a pas repris en c4
il a pris ses six autres choc de
l'américain les amis il a pris ses six
îles oubliées qui avait tout repenser 6
ça va égaliser
allez ça va égaliser les amis il était
à l'aise dans la rue disent le joueur
américain il n'était pas à l'aise
allez il faut terminer le taf
là il est complètement gagnant qui avait
g5 c'est bien joué
allez là il faut faire le taf il faut
faire le taf les gars pièce de plus ces
pièces de plus c'est pas fini mais bon
ça commence à sentir bon
non mais sa santé qui jouait mal dans
cette partie rainn wilson il est pas du
tout à l'aise avec cette ouverture
il est pas à l'aise et là le joueur
français qui a une position écrasante à
présent aller il va faire cavalier aussi
ses tours ses sept à mon avis ms
santé orange qui a pris la mauvaise
décision mauvais jugement de l'américain
préparation intéressante parce que ça
nous a mis en difficulté clairement dans
l'ouverture
ok mais là il va faire tout reprendre et
si ce fardeau il va aller
un tour prend des six ça attaque la dame
et il va y avoir des découvertes à l'esa
art 1 1 orange qui a vraiment une bonne
idée
en fait la ruine et est clairement une
bonne idée il a bien pris le facteur
point faible de ce hard auch donc bravo
à orange pour ça en revanche en revanche
il n'a pas assez bien juger le le level
de rainn wilson dans ses positions là et
il a il a mal jugé le il a mal jugé
qu'il aurait trop de mal à jouer ses
positions
ça
c'est pas prêt
tout reprendre et six en fait c'est un
pion gratuit là il réfléchit beaucoup
trop et au pire fait j'ai trois mais ok
mais tu peux pas tant qu'une minute là
il se met tellement la pression se met
tellement la pression c'est fou en fait
faut juge ou un coup au pire fait j'ai
trois ans mais c'est fou de tank et deux
minutes ici ffu prendre et si c'est très
bien aussi
ok tour c'est cette tu gagnes la dame
quand même et c'est simple comme c'est
simple comme comme une éponge à gagner
ça après l'armée tour ces sept là tu
peux pas ne pas voir c'est pas possible
les amis allez ça va c'est jouer rennes
où il sonne qui a bien un troll celle-là
et dames cet échec ça se voit aussi ou
dames 5 dame prend à schwyz encore plus
facile hélas il ne peut plus rien
arriver c'est gagné
rennes où il sonne qui va abandonner les
amis ça va faire un partout à les dames
prend ensuite c'est terminé à dos ça
c'est un rat table d'un proche cette
dame projet six échecs ça tu ne peux pas
rater simple
le sourire d'un bébé ça il ne peut plus
raté d'un projet 6 dame prend f5
il prend son temps c'est bien il suit
les préceptes est ok ça prend le
football il n'y a plus rien n'y a plus
rien à voir les amis ça égalise à les
dames f5 dam des cinq ans les mois ses
pions là on n'a plus besoin de sur
l'échiquier ça il a même plus à y penser
les gays légalise ada qui arrive à les
dames c'est dedans prend des deux
on continue la rade
dame prend c'est quand même simple ici
maintenant
il faut juste à terminer
me daems et 6 où il faut faire gaffe aux
pattes mais n'y en a jamais y avions
acquis peut bouger est allé un fait une
deuxième dame des cinq des six c'est
pareil
l'armée peut
parce qu'à le pion à qui est mobile en
fait et quand tu le prends et voilà puis
on prend en passant et dames bessette
matt peut pas y avoir deux pattes ya des
pièces côté noir et dames bessette et
dan bessette maths et celle égalisa da
et ben voilà
donc
bon ok
à voir ce qu'il fait
on va voir ce qu'il fait donc il va ré
pt on va voir ce qui s'y réussi à placer
le fourbe et 5g pacy eure rennes où il
sonne va répéter ou pas on va voir
la bon allez c'est sans rajout est ok il
a changé il a pris des cinq prix des 5
on va voir comment
développement des pièces on va voir ce
qu'il nous fait il va développer le fou
tu vas le matin de 7 ans d66 lemay en
recettes
il va pouvoir rockets bonvin position
normale la sortie de l'ouverture on va
voir ce que ça donne
maintenant il joue vite ouais bah c'est
plutôt à son avantage le 5 + 0 je pense
même si rennes où il sonne un plus gros
et look lui elle a quand même 13 185 en
blitz
il fait tomber 5 maintenant fou 17 ok
c'est pas obligatoire mais montant qui
joue vite ça le fait qu'être 8 ça va
une position correcte il a fait
si ce tempo que j'aime bien le fait
qu'ils jouent vite et qui met la
pression autant je pense que c'est la
meilleure stratfor regagné en vrai ce
qu'il est en train de faire donc c'est
parfait doit juste drones annoncé un
live c'est pas un armageddon en fait
comme à leur niveau il n'ya jamais nul
ils font un mort subite et rennes où ils
sont allés blanc parce qu'il a une
meilleure place dans les groupes
donc évidemment c'est un avantage mais
bon après après on a vu la dernière fois
que finalement âge les noirs contre lui
dit que c'était pas mal donc il a joué
deux des quatre c'est c'est bien joué il
fait p5 quoi ils jouent ils jouent vite
il ouvre il franchement franchement là
il fait ce qu'il doit faire sarde
il fait exactement ce qu'il doit faire
jouer vite mettre la pression
sarlat choisi les noirs bizarre comme
choix mais bon allez faut mettre le
cavalier e 4 maintenant qui a fait ses
quatre c'est bien il enferme le fou java
f4 ça fait rien du tout c'est un joli
plan mais ça fait rien il peut mettre le
fou en d6 aller il faut gagner au
continuer s'ils continuent à jouer vite
comme ça il fait tellement mal aux dames
pression sur le cavalier des fous des
six jouets c'est encore un bon cours il
joue comme nico et dans le premier match
il joue vite et il fait pas de fautes
pour le moment à les cavaliers de quatre
bras ça il peut tellement le voir
cavalier e 4 ça fait tellement mal un
coup comme cavalier e 4 ça attaque la
dame qui fait dames c'est cette c'est
bien joué aussi
c'est pas le top coup mais ses coups
numéro 2 ça attaque le cavale plus de 20
pour rennes où il sonne à les boumeurs
il faut craquer côté rennes
la pluie va tomber va s'abattre
quelqu'un valliot 5 bien joué mais
peut-être à du cavalier e 4 et f6 qui
peut traîner en tout cas qui a valu à
quatre ça donne envie
je stresse un petit peu là honnêtement à
les cavaliers 4 jouer ça aurait été
mieux dans l'autre sens mais c'est quand
même pas mal moi surtout ce que j'aime
c'est voir les deux minutes chez rennes
je vous rappelle qu'il ya pas de rage ou
deux tendances celle là est sûre f6 qui
est prince et six fois f4 le coup
intermédiaire il peut le voir aller f6
f6 cavaliers processes fouet f4 et il
peut être très proche de gagner une
pièce avec des coûts intermédiaires m6
il va le voir sarthe c'est sûr et
cavaliers france et si je pense qu'il
doit être juste être gagnant après un
truc comme fou prend un f4 et fou bouge
en d2 au pire ifef si ce jeu serait ce
trop là les gars je tremble pour lui
c'est terrible ces terres
ben là c'était riveraine wilson qui est
mal qui a une 40
non il n'a pas fait fou prend un f4 le
coup intermédiaire sa marque de fabrique
mais ce n'est pas grave il a joué tempo
et rennes qui est très mal aux deux
temps très très mal autant et il menace
des découvertes c'est pas grave du tout
parce que dame français si ça a été
jouée tempo dame f3 il est passé pas
loin quand même de gagner à les pousser
cette dame des six a l'air cool si le
voit non y'a cavaliers prend des sacs et
s'est terminée parce que sur dame des
sept tours prend le cadre d'un prend des
saints qui aura tout reprend 8
non non non non non cavaliers des deux
matches mais louis il a gagné il a gagné
les amis il a gagné les amis c'est
extraordinaire ce extraordinaire j'ai lu
écrire direct j'ai extraordinaire ouah
je suis trop content pour lui oh il a
été magique les amis au ca
être aux plays off watch de une tour f1
et cavaliers des deux matt aut ça fait
trop plaisir ça me fait très franchement
trop plaisir à sa mère
trop plein pour lui c'est qu'il sera
vraiment content d'avoir gagné ça me
fait vraiment trop trop plaisir pour lui
on a eu peur on a eu peur mais c'est
gagné
et voilà les amis la france remporte le
poc chaîne iii ça fait
seize même cave n'a pas vu ouais c'est
surtout pierrois chat c'est surtout qui
a droit à xare que excès perdant tout de
suite mais bon j'ai juste pas eu le
temps de voir
c'est interdit nadeau mais c'est passé
renshaw
sueur bref un visa
t'es sûr avec peu de temps je vous ai
dit qu'il pouvait gaffé et ça a gagné il
avait pas vu et oui juste fourchette web
ac s'est bien passé un jeu
m moi ça fait plaisir je vais envoyer un
petit raid on va essayer de récup sarde
en interview merci merci d'avoir suivi à
temps et je vais changer le titre
trop plaisent allègements